i do need to start today with an apology
um for everything i've ever said on the
show
that has upset somebody uh no i'm
kidding i i want to apologize because
i did a little bit of a cleaning in the
studio you could call it sort of a
bleaching
you of sorts and i didn't realize
that two furniture elements
that are normally separated where my
microphone is connected to something
that is nowhere near me just so i can't
inadvertently create any
gunks in the audio two thing two
elements were touching that should not
have been touching the last two days and
i didn't even realize that i was
regularly creating a sort of a
noise with the microphone people sent me
as you can imagine extremely polite
messages about it
and i've resolved it okay i've resolved
it so i do want to apologize for that
but
let's not dwell on the negative we are
really
starting to get to the next phase
which i would believe to be the end
phase of the coronavirus pandemic
as cases are now down nearly 90 percent
in the united states
deaths are down nearly 85 percent
but but but vaccination continues to
slow down as there are now way more
vaccines
in the u.s than the number of people
that seem to want them at least
relatively quickly which is
sad and we're going to talk about that
much of that lack of demand
is because of republicans this isn't a
bipartisan thing
four percent of democrats don't want the
vaccine
41 percent of republicans don't want the
vaccine as we discussed yesterday
let's go through the case and death
numbers as we now have them cases in the
united states
peaking in mid-january around 255 000 a
day
now down to an average of 32 000 a day
that is a decline of about 87
from that pandemic peak there are some
states where cases are
they're not literally zero but they are
almost statistically zero places like
california that now have
really really low rates and they're
continuing down as more and more people
get vaccinated
in terms of deaths things are not yet
looking
as good deaths lag
changes in cases by about three to four
weeks
but nevertheless deaths are now down
about 82 percent
from a pandemic peak in late january we
were at
34.50 a day that's like 9 11
plus 10 percent every day in deaths in
late january
we are now down to just a hair over 600
deaths a day
still way too high to be calling this
anything close to over
but the right direction continues and
that direction
is down now one factor that is slowing
down the decline
is that fewer and fewer people are
getting vaccinated each day this
is not because there aren't enough
vaccines or not enough appointments
just about every state many pharmacy
chains
chains many locations have switched to
just show up
no appointment needed just get over here
and we'll give you a vaccine
we have more than enough vaccines to go
around we have vaccines here
like countries around the world are
dreaming of having that's not an
exaggeration
but 41 of republicans
and 24 percent of all americans don't
want the vaccine
and so after peaking at about 3.3
million
doses per day in early april we have
seen almost a 50
decline to now just 1.8 million doses
per day
this is embarrassing look around the
world
countries around the world are doing
everything they can
to get vaccines there are countries that
are happy to get half a million vaccines
we have millions and millions of them
just sitting around ready
and we have millions and millions
millions of people saying nah i don't
want to get one
the cases and the deaths would decline
way more quickly
if more people got vaccinated just think
we're vaccinating about half of the
number we were vaccinating a month ago
each day we could be seeing cases
decline
significantly faster if we just got back
to where we were
3.3 million vaccines per day we could
open everything sooner and more safely
if more people got vaccinated now what's
going on globally
because the u.s led from the standpoint
of
bad early in the pandemic we are now
leading from the standpoint of good in
terms of the vaccination
but the u.s is not the world what's
going on with global numbers
the good news is that global cases and
global deaths are now
clearly starting to come down 10 days
ago it looked like okay they were
leveling off but where will things go
globally cases peaked at about 830 000
cases per day
in later april we're now down to about
665 000 a day it's an outrageous number
but it's down 20 from the peak that's
good
global deaths similarly to the picture
in the u.s
global deaths are declining but lagging
the case decline
global deaths peaked at about 14 000 a
day back in january can you imagine
almost got back there in april and we
are now down to about 12 000 deaths a
day that's a decline of 15
from the peak but there is a long way to
go globally and
part of why it's so depressing to know
that we have the vaccines for everyone
but to see
in the united states people opting out
is that the vaccines are why the u.s is
doing better and better this is a very
similar thing to the measles
anti-vaxxers and it's
depressing doesn't even really cut it
you have measles anti-vaxxers who say
who dies of measles why would i go and
get my kid vaccinated
for measles the reason almost no one
dies of measles
is the vaccination campaign has been so
effective and the vaccine is so
effective
were it not for that then people would
be dying of measles
people are saying some cases are going
down
this is ending i don't need to get the
vaccine but the reason why they're going
down
is we have so many vaccines it's a
privilege to have access to so many
vaccines
an incredible headline multiple states
reported
zero covet deaths on single days over
the last week for the first time in
months
this includes arizona minnesota
massachusetts maryland and others
now of course weekend reporting can
throw off the meaning of
any single day's data but the averages
are declining
things are opening and that is all great
just go and get vaccinated
it's free you just show up there's a
vaccine available
and maybe this will be more of an
incentive for people to get vaccinated
although i
think the people not getting vaccinated
don't care about this
the european union has announced hours
ago
they will be opening to vaccinated
americans let's talk about
that next one of our sponsors is magic
spoon the breakfast cereal that tastes
just like the sugary tasty cereals we
all loved as kids but
without the sugar and without the carbs
magic spoon is sweet and delicious with
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein
and only four net carbs making it
perfect for a low carb
or keto diet and very exciting news
magic spoon has released an awesome new
flavor birthday cake
available for a limited time only but
you can still get cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon you can build your own variety
pack
our team has tried every flavor we've
looked at each flavor
really strongly and we keep asking them
to just send us more
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video